the jurogan experience he he performs
like it doesn't exist
like cancer culture doesn't exist kind
of like the way jack johnson just kind
of
jack john you ever see that documentary
jack johnson um
yeah he just like lived his life as if
racism didn't exist and people like
didn't even know what to make of him
than a lot of white chicks he did
in their face during a time where like
you get lynched for that [ __ ] he was
he almost seemed like he was taken from
another era and put into
he would talk [ __ ] while he was [ __ ]
you up he had gold t he had gold fronts
i mean before hip hop i mean he like he
almost looks like he was like
time traveled yeah well you know it's
interesting his nickname was the
galveston giant
you know he was only like six feet tall
or six foot one i think
i don't think he was even i i might have
been 200 pounds
yeah you know like how pull up how tall
and how much
did jack johnson weigh six foot tall
yeah galveston giant a giant six you're
six foot tall right yeah yeah how crazy
is that you're a giant
yeah people had no food back then yeah
they didn't grow that big they didn't
have any food
dude yeah this is how [ __ ] soft we
are yeah people were tiny back then like
if you look at the the average size of
the civil war yeah
an average man was 130 pounds yeah
because they didn't have any [ __ ]
food yeah
they must have looked like abe lincoln
like holy [ __ ] this guy's tall
six two not that big yeah i mean yeah
but jack johnson
was guys got big balls literally look at
that package zach
huge [ __ ] i'm sure yeah look at that
right there i mean you got to think this
is there's no steroids back then
yeah there's just superior genetics and
also
just [ __ ] hardship right you know
talk about
khabib growing up in dagestan imagine
being a black man
as a boxer back when they all wanted
white men to be the champ
look at the size of him man yeah
shredded he was shredded
built like uh like a modern elite
athlete
yeah and this is you know what year was
that turn of the century
what year was it jamie didn't say that
he was a champ
was it like 1908 like early early turn
of the century
i started eating a little bit there what
can you do buster douglas it happens
in between fights what's that right
there yeah he looks like he had a couple
of cheeseburgers or whatever
well what does it say here just say
there
it says uh he was born in
he died in 46.
he was born in 1878 wow
so it's probably the early early 1900s
and but they would get giant ass crowds
and you barely could see
anything yeah you know and all guys had
top hats you ever see the the crowds
yeah they're wild yeah city lost over
100 pounds to get into that fight
what in 1910 yeah he hadn't fought in
six years and had to lose well over 100
pounds to get back into his championship
fighting
weight really yeah
it was yeah he's probably just drinking
and eating yeah
living like a killer the guy he fought
oh who'd he fight was that jefferies
yeah yeah yeah james jeffries yeah yeah
oh well that makes sense
well they brought jeffries in to try to
beat him because jefferies was the
former champion and
he was a big kid too right jim jeffries
like he's a big fellow yeah
but you know they were that's where the
great white hope kind of probably
originated
they were trying to beat him oh yeah
yeah sure that's exactly where it came
from yeah
and then he was he was about to win that
fight and they cut the broadcast
what's happening they cut the cast back
yeah they there was like the first
televised boxing match
and he was a i forget who he was
fighting some white guy number five or
six
whatever they were putting up this is uh
but before he knocked them out they just
caught the broadcast because they didn't
want the country to see it they had
broadcasts back then
it's towards the end yeah i mean like uh
yeah fight
huh i think it was that fight it wasn't
that fun
when did they have tv when did tv what
was the first television broadcast
i want to say 1940.
was the first let's let's figure out
when the first television broadcast was
yeah i mean his
i know that i can guess one's the first
television i'm gonna say like uh 1917.
yeah back in the day people would talk
like yeah why didn't they talk like that
hey welcome to the fight yeah 1928 was
the first broadcast
so one of his fights was broadcast right
i don't know man
it was one of the states they owned it i
don't know
i don't think they did i don't think
they did
i want to say if that was the case it
was like
way late in his career they think like
even like when he lost
he like lost later in his career they
think he took a dive
because there's a there's a video of it
where it doesn't really look like he's
hurt he just
lays down like they might have
threatened him or
you know he might have got a big payday
to take a dive
there's always a lot of speculation in
boxing yeah about guys taking dives
especially the mob was heavily involved
in it oh yeah
my god you might imagine the amount of
money you could win betting on a white
guy against jack johnson yeah a lot of
money
yeah a lot of ways one of his quotes i
remember like he was so wild
i think he got he used to like drive a
fast car he made some money and
it was fast back then 35 35 miles an
hour yeah
like wow he uh he got a ticket and the
guy he was like hey don't give me a
ticket now he was like because i'm going
to
drive back yeah you give me two tickets
well he no what it was is that they gave
him a ticket for fifty dollars because
here's a hundred because i'm gonna be
going the same speed the way back
wow yeah that's not giving a [ __ ] i mean
he
had no [ __ ] to give yeah i mean what
are you gonna do
guys like him almost like uh when you
look at history like um
you know is this sort of just a natural
evolution thing like now certain guys
move history forward
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah certain human
beings
are so spectacular in their time frame
that it changes what we expect
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience